have you had any conversations or talks
with junior at all
who's joe gotti junior
no
no no talks no
you know what the world would be curious
to see
it'd be very interesting if the two of
you guys had to sit down and i know you
would never do it i know you wouldn't no
no no no i'm not interested in sitting
down with him
see michael was a different story i i
don't hate i didn't even when i didn't
get along with michael i didn't hate him
i think that he said certain things that
were not true about me about john about
a few things that he said i saw him now
in a new one
where he was walking up and down my chin
in the bathrobe
before that
and chen told them if junior doesn't
make you a captain i'll make you one of
my family
makes sense okay yeah we don't even want
to talk about that
didn't have nobody come to him
there was a made guy in the columbo
family
who
used his name
giganti
he had him called then he was this close
this guy to get killed because he used
his name
so
he wasn't the boss
it was a powerhouse
i mean
and he was tough but he was pretty fair
in different ways
i mean i had a couple of good decisions
and one of the decisions is
he
there was a whole hit it's a long story
i'm not going to get into it but when at
the end he called me down again for a
final meeting
and i had permission to whack a few
people and he said i want you to do me a
favor
to these kids
that
you could hurt belong to a friend of
ours
we took him out
we take care of his wife and those kids
i want to ask you for a favor give them
a pass they were that wrong that he had
is
and i said okay
i will do that but i want to ask you for
a favor
he was a boss
i was just a
pup
acting captain
he said what
i said this kid's capacity who gave me
all this information and caused this
whole thing he's with you people
i know now that you know this whole
thing
you're going to wind up killing him
because he came to us and not use
he created this
what do you want i want you to give him
a pass
he saved my life this kid
i'll give him give him a pass and i'll
give those two kids you want to piss
that's pretty smart tammy he put his
hand out we shook hands
and nobody got killed
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]